this is a production of cornell
university
okay thank you so much theresa it's
quite an introduction
i will i am confident that i'll live up
to it in this presentation
about pockets because it's one of my
favorite things to talk about
so um although teresa is right i haven't
worked in this system for a little bit
most recently i've been working with a
different kind of symbiosis with
endobacteria and our business horizon
fungi you'll hear more about that next
time
the timing is fortuitous here because
i've got a chapter coming out soon a
book chapter
on these little organs these pockets
you can see them here on the silhouettes
the uh
here we get that circle starting again
oh never mind
i also sparred myself well pockets
i think that these fungus pockets are
completely under appreciated in ambrosia
beetles
uh and i think ambrosia beetles are far
too obscure in the first place
so what am i here to do i'm here to tell
you about
fungus pockets and sell you on the fact
that they are the greatest
symbiotic organ that's ever existed and
that everyone should know about them
and tell other people how cool they are
and so let's see how i do on that
here's a photo of a beetle it's a cute
little beetle
right uh notice there's something
in the front of the beetle the pronoun
area it almost
looks fake it looks like a paper clip
inside the beatles body or something
what is that
if we hey here's a 3d image of whatever
that thing is that looks wild it's like
a hose pipe
rolled up inside of the body um here's a
photo through a microscope you can see
it
through the transparent exoskeleton of
the beetle what the heck is that
here the tube's been taken out and it's
been smashed under a microscope slide
and what look like fungus spores
are being squeezed out like toothpaste
what is this mysterious tube
well i'll get back to that
here's a beautiful illustration showing
some
wonderful wood insects
notice the beautiful designs some of
them make on wood
these engraving beetles as they dig
tunnel as their larvae dig tunnels
through
the phloem in the inner
and outer bark notice the same up here
beautiful patterns in the park beautiful
patterns in the park
these are bark beetles maybe you've seen
their evidence around town when you've
peeled
a piece of bark off the tree and if you
haven't
start peeling in places where you're
allowed to feel bark and
you'll eventually find some works of art
but something different is happening
at the bottom right these tunnels are
going straight
into the tree and that's weird because
there's not a lot of food there phloem
is great
it's full of sugary phloem
and that's a good food source it makes
sense that there'd be a lot of
competition
to want to live there but who in their
right mind would dive into the sap wood
the dead part of the tree where there's
almost nothing
who indeed well i can tell you the
answer is ambrosia beetles
and ambrosia beetles don't just live
there they continue
to live there and they pack up all the
time
and live there again and it's not by
living on the terrible nutrients inside
of that wood
it is by farming fungi actual
insect agriculture the fungi
concentrate the nutrients from the wood
into something the beetles can eat
the beetles eat the fungi it's a simple
relationship we do the same thing with
corn
we don't eat soil generally right but
corn kind of does and we like to eat
corn it's the same
relationship the beetles are farming a
cultivated fungus
to extract nutrients from this sapwood
now this ambrosia fungus it's very
delicate and it can't disperse on its
own it's become so
good at becoming delicious food it makes
these huge juicy spores that the beetles
love to eat but these spores are so big
they just collapse and die the instant
they hit
dry open air they need to be in these
humid tunnels to survive
and considering there's so many other
hardy or fungi waiting in the wood to
take over
to cover the tunnels to attach
themselves to the beetles
how the heck do ambrosia beetles fly to
new trees almost every year
and start new perfectly pure gardens
of the same fungus cultivar
how do they keep their crops i'll get
back to that
let me tell you about laurel will
because i know this is a plant pathology
seminar
and i've made sure to include some plant
pathology material
despite uh being part of plant pathology
departments
for gosh okay
some years uh i'm only kind of a plant
pathologist that's what happens to my
colleges sometimes right
but almost anyone should have heard of
laurel wilt in the plant pathology
world this is an ambrosia beetle fungus
combo introduced to georgia in the early
2000s
that within 15 years killed 300 million
red bay trees and threatens every other
member of the lauraceae
that includes things like camphor
sassafras and
oh yeah avocado a tree that a lot of
people have a good relationship with
it was thought to have originated with a
single introduction from a shipping
container
maybe even a single female beetle
how is that possible how could a single
beetle start an epidemic
i'll get back to that right now because
the answer to all three of these
questions
that i posed so
tentatively is the same answer
what is this mysterious to how do
ambrosia beetles keep their crops
how can one beetle start an epidemic
pockets did you expect anything else
it's the
topic of this talk
just like we use pockets of different
sizes to carry different things ambrosia
beetles use
pockets that are kind of like the
artist's depiction here
to carry fungi and just like different
sized pockets carry
different things different ambrosia
bueno fungus pockets
carry different fungi and that's really
important
and it is well worth learning about and
understanding
what these pockets are and how they work
so powerful pockets
how these pockets define fungus farming
and ambrosia beetles
let's start with a pretty important
question what are ambrosia beetles
anyway i've been using that word a lot
like everyone knows
and is familiar with it well it's simple
they're beetles that farm
fungi and xylem kind of
because there's a few caveats they
tunnel into southwood
sometimes they will go into heartwood or
pith
and they farm lush gardens of ambrose
fungi look at the beautiful
white lawn here they do have parental
care and various levels of sociality
there's even a youth social species that
has an ant colony like
multi-generational
lifestyle but it's just one species but
here the mother beetle
is tending to these larvae which are
enjoying their entire life in one little
cradle
with all the food they could ever need
growing around them the ambrosia
here you can see how they tunnel deep
into the wood itself and the bright
white fungus growing inside
our ambrosia beetle is a taxonomic group
that would be convenient
absolutely not ambrosia beetles evolved
more than
12 different times in two families of
true weevils that's right they are true
weevils
that have simply lost their snouts
because snouts kind of get in the way
when you're digging in wood
the first is the family platypodinae and
this unrooted tree here
from holster and stalinski 2017 you're
going to see the more of this tree
here's the platypodine all by itself um
all of them are ambrosia beetles every
single species but starting here and
everything else in this tree is the
family skeleton
and of those six thousand skeleton a
about 3 500
are ambrosia beetles the rest are mostly
bark beetles there's a few that are
things like
uh seed borers and pith borers and
things
but most of the rest are bark beetles
now
you might be wondering if you're
somewhat familiar with the system well
aren't ambrosia beetles bark beetles
kind of bark beetles is used
colloquially to refer to
the entire scalidone which includes all
of the ambrosia beetles
within but in rosy beetles aren't really
in the bark
and the original definition of ambrosia
beetle was to distinguish it from
bark beetles so i don't consider amongst
beetles bark beetles
instead ambrosia beetle is an ecological
term that for most of its history
has been used to distinguish them from
something else bark beetles
so what's the difference the problem
with using a definition
based on being not something else
is that it gets pretty messy over time
and i'll explain in a bit you certainly
can't just
look at a skeleton and decide if it's a
frozen beetle or a bark beetle unless
you're an expert of course
they look really similar these are
examples of both
that we can find here uh and
to most people they just kind of look
like weird beetles i mean this one looks
like it's gone through an accident
um it's kind of been amputated it uses
that surface to
plug the entrance of its tunnels in from
intruders
so it's basically like a built-in door
but they're visually similar the
evidence they do in nature because of
their different ecology is not similar
here's a photo i took in my yard here
just like a couple months ago
after peeling some bark away those are
the beautiful engraved galleries of bark
beetles
here we see what are commonly known as
frass noodles
or toothpicks ambrosian beetles dig
really far into the wood and they have
to push all that frass out and for
whatever reason
that frass sticks together really
tightly and it forms little noodles
so if you ever see noodles sticking out
of a tree and you think someone's made
some kind of prank with spaghetti
it is almost certainly ambrosia beetles
i took this photo in uh
near cliffs of varna up in monkey run
here in
ithaca but this difference has been
appreciated for a really long time
this photo is actually i don't know the
source but it's public domain
but um beautiful vintage art here
showing the difference between bark
beetle and rosy good galleries
and now might be a good time for me to
demonstrate
depending on if you have the speaker
camera on if you do i have the whole
right side of the slide available for
you to
put the video bar in but uh here's a
nice example of some ambrosia beetle
tunnels well in this case they're
actually cradles or the larvae would eat
they're extremely small here's a
bookmark that i got from a good
friend and collaborator and you can see
there's a cross section of a few hybrid
b double tunnels
there they're really really little
and they're ecologically very different
from bark beetles
so i'm going to return to this beautiful
picture again because it illustrates
this difference
all the bark beetles versus the ambrosia
beetles in the wood
and this was recognized more than a
hundred years ago this is hubbard in
1895 and
the paper that defined the word ambrosia
beetle the ambrosia beetles the united
states and hubbard simply
defines them as a term to distinguish
them from the true
bark borers as those that push their
galleries deeply into the wood and feed
upon
ambrosia which was known to be a fungus
so that's the two definitions right
easy so all beetles all and brochure
beetles tunnel into the xylem
all bark beetles total into the phloem
that's great
um all beetles all ambrosia beetles are
obligate fungus farmers
so it only makes sense that all bark
beetles are
not obligate fungus farmers right well
this is where it starts to get messy
because some bark beetles benefit or
require fungus
to develop fully a lot of them have
really tight associations with fungi
they get uh just about as close as you
can get to being called
farming they even have well i almost got
ahead of myself the symbiosis with fungi
with bark beetles can be extremely
complex
and so uh really the only thing
different is they're doing it in the
bark
it starts to become a little arbitrary
all ambrosia beetles have fungus pockets
surely this must be something unique to
ambrosia beetles
no some bark beetles also have fungus
pockets
some of them extremely complicated and
complex
especially those that rely on those
fungi
i say all this because these words are
mixed up all the time
in the ambrosh biddlebark beetle world
and it's kind of understandable because
the line between them is very blurry
and it's based entirely on a group of
more than 12 different unrelated
lineages that do the same thing
to put them apart from something else
but keep all that in mind because i'll
be mentioning ambrosia beetle and bark
beetle
oh what's the oh that's right sorry i
got totally off topic i'm supposed to be
talking about
pockets so okay uh so
pockets full of pathogens
so all disease-causing bark or ambrosia
beetles have
pockets full of pathogens this is a
common assumption after all
maybe the most famous of barcaman
brochure beetles cause disease
and if they have symbiosis with fungi
then it must be the fungi causing them
right
this is really not generally the case
let me first introduce
dutch elm disease ophiostoma novo olmi
this should be
very familiar to everyone including
important work that was done here
on the early disease pictured as just
one of the three
vectors in the u.s this does not have
pockets
full of pathogens because it doesn't
have pockets
this beetle does not have symbiosis
sorry does not have mutualism
with the dutch own disease fungus and it
doesn't have the fungus pockets to carry
it
dutch elm disease is just really good at
sticking to the surface of beetles
that's part of why it can be vectored by
three different ones it has really
sticky
spores the fungus certainly benefits
from the transmission
but it's unclear if the beetle is
getting much in return especially in the
way of nutrition
ah laurel wilt yes it does have pockets
full of pathogens
these same fungus that look that this uh
red bay and frozen butyl introduces into
trees
that kills the trees is the fungus it
farms
and eats to survive and does in its
native
range as well so yeah the fungus that
causes disease
and the mutualists are one and the same
southern pine beetle that's one of the
many
destructive bark beetles in the u.s
pockets but no pathogen
it has incredibly complex pockets
you they look just as amazing as some of
the most uh large in ambrosia beetles
and it definitely holds two different
mutualists one and ask them i see one of
the city on my seat that the beetle
feeds on
but it's not the fungi that cause the
majority if any of the disease it's the
mass
attacked by the beetles the physical
damage
and finally the black stem board which
should be very familiar to some here
because there
is at least one if not more groups here
at cornell in geneva
working on black stem bore especially in
where it's a nursery
or uh orchard pest it does have pockets
and it does have a mutualist that it
eats
it farms to eat but that mutualism is
not the fungus that causes
disease in fact again it's the beetle
itself that causes most of the
mechanical damage
that actually dooms trees although it
gets even more complicated
because it can vector some somewhat
pathogenic fusarium
either on the surface or in the
micangium along with the neutralist
so now you can start to see why this
entire thing is full of caveats
everywhere and i can only cover some of
them but i think it's important
because you know how we learn more about
all these things
by learning about the pockets i'll get
back to that
of course again plant pathology seminar
i want to touch on the
economically important ambrosia beetles
in the usa
past september many species too many to
talk about cortis colombianis is a
well-known one because it makes
little flags in the wood it's called
flag warm
often and it'll attack living trees
sometimes most of them are attacking
timber already cut
felled or cut trees
nursery and orchard pests there's two
big ones in the u.s
the granulated ambrosia butyl and the
black stem bore that i mentioned
before both of them are
really serious pests and nurseries and
orchards especially
there's a few others including ana
sandra's mage which only just arrived
here
hasn't been too much of a problem yet
nessus muolatus
anzales sanders compactus or other uh
invasive pests
but these two are by far the biggest
problems but these are
the signal alert uh pathogens right now
these are the big deals in the country
and they're on both
uh sides they're on both shores the
first
laurel will which i mentioned red bay
and rose butyl vectors the laurel wilt
pathogen raphael de la ricola
the second are two different polyphagus
shot holes borer species
in california well i should say the
polyphagus shahabor and the caricio shot
hold boar i'm just going to use
pshb for now on for this because that's
a lot to say for both
uh they both vector vascular fusarium
dieback
pathogens and they're causing big
problems in california
note i'm not going to list all the bark
beetles that cause big disease they are
bark beetles that includes thousand
cankers disease
mountain pine beetle southern pine
beetle etc we're just going to focus on
frozen beetles
the thing about pest september is that
this has been known for a long time
since the early 1900s and it's been
known that they're really picky about
that wood
that the wood has to be of excellent
quality and recently killed and just
moist enough
uh and it hasn't dried out too much and
then the ambrosia beetles will attack
dig in make their galleries and ruin
that wood
i mean although i kind of i like it i
like the wood for making crafts with
generally it would ruin timber it causes
millions of dollars of damage
but this is the normal biology of
ambrosia beetles
they with only a few exceptions are
geared to attack
stressed dying and recently dead trees
that way they don't have to deal with
tree defenses
they're going for trees that are already
on their way out
or are stressed and can't defend
themselves for this reason ambrosia
beetles are
really frequently blamed for killing
trees
when they're almost always innocent but
you see a tree dying it's only it's got
a bunch of noodles
coming out of it spaghetti noodles it's
easy to blame
the beetles mass attacks though
this is another problem so both of the
major nursery and orchard pests
do this look how many noodles are coming
off of that tree
there's no way that could be good so
this basically girdles the tree by
punching so many holes in it
making so many tunnels that the bachelor
can no longer support the tree
they support they attack in huge masses
which overwhelm the tree
the same thing happens with the
polyphagus shot hole borer
but uh the effects of the fungus are a
lot more evident but still
the fungus is not a one inoculation kill
it works in tandem with mass attacks by
the butyl
overall tree's defenses cause these
terrible scars and die back
and eventually uh death
now in each case fungus can help
this uh mortality maybe the non-mutual
cesarean in the granulate
and the black shot holbor sorry in the
black ambrosia beetle
that's not super well shown but sure
they have fusion associated with them it
can cause
symptoms it's certainly not the
mutualist fungus
polyphagus shot hull bore definitely the
fungus
aids in the symptoms and it is the
nutritional symbiont that they farm
as well but finally the true
wilt disease laurel will the only true
wealth disease
vectored by an ambrosia beetle um
there is another rafaeli disease in
japan raphaeli persephora
i'm going to stick with the us for now
so uh
this is a true wilt disease the fungus
is the killer now
whether it's because the tree commits
suicide by making too many tyloses
in response to the fungus or the fungus
gums up the vasculature
uh well i'm not the person to ask i'm
not sure if it's still in the literature
remember i'm only kind of a plant
pathologist
but this is definitely a big deal it
runs rampant on loraciae trees look how
brown those leaves are
look at that open part of the tree with
all the tunnels
this is a big threat i asked earlier how
can one
beetle start an epidemic um
well now i can actually answer answer it
fully it's not just
pockets because one part is that
the red bambrosia butyl like all
xylibrine and frozen beetles
uh is can uh the females can start
they're happily deployed so they can
start an entire population on their own
if they're pregnant
add my kanji in with that carrying the
perfect fungus from the native country
and when the fetal invaded from asia
it already had the pathogenic fungus the
fungus which trees were pretty resistant
to
in asia ready to go so the answer is
pockets
so i want to quickly uh cover the
publications per year that include the
word ambrosia beetle because i think
this tells an important story
the word was defined in the late 1800s
yes here in 32 blackstone board was
introduced to the us here in new york
okay 1932 that's supposed to be 1974.
that's okay the granite leader in moscow
was introduced in south carolina
another both of those nursery and
orchard pests suddenly
laurel wilt hit it was noticed a few
years earlier but this is the year it
was really appreciated
and suddenly we have something then
2012 poly figure shot hold war in
california
and it's been nothing but up since then
now i did my
phd in in this
region uh sorry about uh right here just
in the most
of the uh the increase now i don't want
to leave out
because again this is just a search on
the number of publications obviously
worldwide
disease could have an impact on this too
so they're a japanese oak disease the
other rafaeli disease did happen in the
late 90s
polyphagus charlemour has hit israel and
south africa and of course those have
contributed to
interest what i'm trying to say here is
that laurel wilt acted as a
spark that incited a lot of interest in
this system
that hadn't been there before despite
the orchard and nursery pests despite
the amazing symbiotic model system which
i'll get to in a bit
it wasn't until these really big
diseases hit that suddenly
erosion beetles really increased in
interest and i checked
this is more than the already
exponential increase in publications in
the world in general
so it's an ambrosial renaissance of some
sort
but for some perspective here there's
five serious pests in the u.s all of
them are invasive i
talked about all five there's about 30
invasive ambrosia beetles total in the
us and canada
there's 86 total ambrosia fetal species
including natives
and there's about 3 500
ambrosia beetle species worldwide and
the
interest that's been put into research
in understanding basic biology is
very outsized for these problematic
species compared to the rest
and they often miss the significance of
pockets
in the ecology of these beetles
oh right pockets okay i got way too far
into plant pathology it's time to get
back to pockets so
what's in a pocket anyway it's about
time we talked about that
i keep calling them fungus pockets and
maybe you're really envisioning
like pants pockets or something but no
they're a lot more amazing than that
let me cut this beetle open here and we
see a strange
little structure if we put that on a
microscope slide if we squish it down
and look closer
it is a membrane filled with pure fungus
spores this is the mutualist this is the
ambrosia fungus that the beetle farms
but that is far from the only example of
a fungus pocket
here we have two little pockets just at
the top of the wing covers
here we have a little bowl on the side
of the body covered in hairs
here we have just two little perfectly
circular dimples that hold
spores you remember the fungus tube from
earlier it might be a clue as to what
that tube is all about
here is a couple more shots of the one i
just showed you it's a big
membrane inside the body here we see
membranes near the mouth so while the
beetle is eating
some spores can go through the esophagus
and get stored winding tubes
big hairy patches there's a lot of
different kinds of fungus pockets
here's a color coded list of the most
well
studied and i know it's a lot but just
appreciate the diversity here
winding hose pipes horse shoes
little fins something that looks like a
ufo upside down in the beetle
it's incredible how different these are
a little sphere inside of the head
all of them separately evolved to hold
fungus spores that's why they look so
different and that's
why they're so incredible how did they
get discovered though
well it was a austrian monk in the early
1800s who noticed the beatles eating
this white stuff and he called ambrosia
it was the mycologist heartache who said
well that's
fungus it's not sap it's a fungus
and it generates spontaneously from the
tree
well he was wrong about that but hubbard
in 1897 said
i think the fungus is under control of
the insect the insect
brings it into the woods somehow and
finally helene frankie grossman the
single most important scientist
in the ambrosia science said it's
difficult to believe they could just
accidentally bring this food with them
on the exoskeleton
so what she did was dissect cleverly a
bunch of different ambrosia beetles and
found
these big conspicuous organs and they
were full of fungus spores
it was a very clever idea
and it answers a question from earlier
how do they keep their crops
it's with the fungus pockets it's not
just when flying tree to tree because
that absolutely is what they're for
they're full of pure spores they go to a
new tree and they start their new garden
but also over winter without the fungus
dying which is the actual question
that drove helen to seek this
answer now she discovered many
right at the beginning but she was
calling them general german names like
help
helpdrusin
or skin poor skin glands what to call
them is there a better name
well is the mycologist elec raj batra
who did some of the most important
early mid 1900's work on ambrosia fungi
who gave
the term mycangia and that is the term
that i use and the most common term
since now if you
are recognized like botra that's because
he used to be
here at cornell as a student under korf
here you can see cor batra about a
decade before
naming the mycangia i have found some
about specimens in teaching herbarium
uh and it's a pretty cool collection um
it's a pretty cool connection so it was
our own
like fatra who gave it the name while he
was working with liquor
and kansas helen frankie grossman would
later say well michael tangia is
probably more correct and
it kind of is grammatically but
mechanism
has been used much more those five years
of lead time were enough
that it took hold especially in the
english-speaking world
mycetangia has been used more in german
and other languages and has had a
resurgence recently
so birth words or use okay let's get to
the most amazing parts of
this organ general features of mycanja
they are enclosed structures that spores
are held inside
narrow openings that the spores come in
and exit and there are gland cells that
secrete
into the lumen
inside of the mycanja are pure fungus
masses
they can be actual budding yeasts like
in raphaelia or they can be phthalic
arthric
hyphy that break off and disarticulate
in either case
these are dimorphic fungi they've
evolved to turn into this form and the
micangem
and then go back to a fluffy beautiful
edible form in wood
and then back again so all strict my
candida fungi so
far have special forms that they take to
grow
and live in the mic engine there's been
great strides in visualization since the
early days i'm not going to linger on
this but it's gone from these beautiful
hand illustrations
to these beautiful 3d images from
combined ct scans
and you can see a few more images here
here was my best attempt a few years ago
at getting
this mechanism on a microscope but how
can you beat color-coded 3d
uh video game looking illustrations it's
just incredible it shows the musculature
it shows the organs in red
it's just extremely cool and for
difficult organs to talk about
it's real oh what's this but are they
just
no of course not they're not just
pockets if they were just pockets to
hold spores
passively there wouldn't be i'd be done
talking about them okay they hold fungi
that's the end
but they're hardly passive pockets they
are ringed with
active gland cells that secrete into the
lumen
i already mentioned that right these
support selective
growth of ambrosia fungi and this is
information that had been in the
literature for a long time
but kind of under the radar it had never
really been combined together
uh and it was first tested
experimentally in this wonderful paper
from 2019
where for the first time different
strains of ambrosia fungi were
artificially put into different micangia
to see what would happen and it turns
out that my kanji aren't just
selective in a broad sense they can
actually have quite specific
selection on different closely related
ambrosian fungi
although there's a mountain of caveats
there too
this was my biggest impetus for putting
this review in this chapter together and
getting this information out was
that this had never been put together in
one place what i'm calling the mycanjump
cycle it's really a theory but it has so
much literature to support every step
individually at least in the
big mycanja that it is a solid
theory and mechanism so first the
ambrosia butyl has an empty micangium
propagules come in from the walls we
know that they aren't very careful about
this
molds nematodes mites all kinds of
things get into these micanja
and hopefully some of the actual
ambrosia fungus the thing that's all
this fluffy white stuff in the gallery
the glands recognize this somehow and
they turn on when the fungus enters
filling the mechanism with something
we're actually not sure what
the propagals propagate but the
non-mycoengine propagules don't
and through simple numbers uh through a
numbers game
the mutualist which is tuned to this
environment grows quickly
and pushes out fungi there aren't tuned
for this environment now this doesn't
mean there aren't
my kanji passengers that have adapted to
this there definitely are
there's great evidence that there's
yeasts adapted to living here
there's great evidence that other fungi
also go along with nutritional
mutualists they may also have other
mutualistic
rules but in general this is how molds
and other common contaminants are gotten
rid of
the beetle flies to a new tree the
fungus continues to grow
overflow from the mechanism i've seen
this myself they're just
got a big glob of it coming out and they
just have to touch the wall of their new
tunnels
to start their new gardens over again
the gland cells turn off at some point
the insides deteriorate and are digested
and
we start the whole cycle again the next
generation pick up the
fungi when they mature and this
mechanism cycle is a really
beautiful and important thing because
this is what allows
everything this is the reason ambrosia
beetles can keep
their special delicate cultivars despite
there being so many other aggressive
fungi
this is how enrolled beetles were able
to domesticate their crops in the first
place
this is how ambrosia beetles make sure
they have pure inoculum when they go
into wood
and it's really important to get a good
inoculum for anyone who's ever grown
mushrooms at home
uh you know that for a fact if you've
done oysters or um
shiitake or organiderma gotta have a
pure inoculum
so um let's talk about the fungi a
little bit and i'm going to go very
quickly through this because
this is usually what i talk about and
this is what most of my thesis was about
but my kanji defined fungal cultivar
that my candida metabutel has defined
what
defines what kind of ambrosian fungus
that beetle farms the smaller mycanja
generally have
raphaelia ambrosia fungi and they share
them
the same fungus between different
beetles one beetle can have more than
one raphaelia
they are not all that picky but the
bigger fungi
a bigger mechanism things like the
coiling hosepipe tubes things like the
big membranes inside the body
they're a lot more precise all of them
have erosion fungi in a totally
different order
the stratocystidaceae and i should say
rafaeli is closely related to dutch
health disease and opiostoma
these threat assisted aca and bronze
bondura closely related to ceratocystis
a very different
tree pathogen with very similar ecology
each of these mechanism types strictly
associated with one
genus of the strength assisted aca
meaning there's some kind of
higher level tuning happening here
between insect organ
and fungus somehow
and these mechanical always carry pure
masses of ambrosia fungi
except for when they have nematodes or
other things in my cancer
my kanji can actually recognize a
nematode inside of them and shut down
and we think that's some of the reason
why some birch beetles have doubled
mycanja so that one can be shut down
i apologize there's some grass cutting
going on outside and so if there's a
background noise that's why
the pro thoracic micangel of of this
group of beetles only has
amphialoprosis syndrome fungi and it's
the same fungus in
the mechanism that grows right along the
walls of the bar they eat the mizunodo
my kanji only has a rosiella
fungi the procoxo coil my canned gem
only has meredith yellow
fungi uh we proved this around the world
with multiple species for each of these
groups and uh write a new dinner for
them that was part of my
thesis and i really love these fungi but
um this answers a question from earlier
what is this mysterious tube
i think you've guessed by now but it is
the spore pocket the mycanjom
of uh in this case the genus worthless
it's my favorite mechanism because it's
so ridiculous
it's a hose pipe that enters through the
armpit that the beetles can squeeze
fungi out of it doesn't get much better
than that
the only better one is well this one
because it's like a ufo whale uh
blowhole
also toothpaste squeezer so if you cut
these beetles open
the skeletal platypodini there's a
little ufo in there and they've got a
blowhole on their back
and there's a little onion bulb looking
thing that fills with spores
that overflow out of the flow hole and
here's a photo of the inside of one
they are filled with these beautiful
hairs that guide the spores up to the
hole
and help them escape and it's thought
the beetle can like move its head back
to squeeze on that
mechanism as well so these mycanjump
fungus associations
have very strong taxonomic patterns as
we showed in for suny and 2020
um and there's co-evolutionary signal
there as well i don't want to
get too far into that i am looking at
the clock i want to talk about one cool
story
side story zalatrina's politis the only
ambrosia people we know of that has
two different mycanja that's not new
news
lawrence abrahamson under the direction
of dale norris worked on these in the
late 60s
as part of his hd work
made beautiful slots um he uh graciously
lent me the slides to take this colored
photo
there's one on my kanjo and there's the
other near the head
two different mechanics one is only in
the females one is in both sexes
again this is unknown in any other
ambrosia butyl
the prothoracic fungus which abrahamson
had isolated but never characterized we
were able to isolate and characterize
just last year and we named it after
uh dr abrahamson in honor of his actual
first discovery back in the 60s
and uh the genus is after uh this and i
know
another methylation carrick a very
respected horse entomologist who just
turned 100 recently
the oral symbiont is another raphaelia
this really promiscuous common ambrosia
fungus group
and so this is interesting why is it you
don't bother to keep both my canja
over evolutionary time why does it have
both fungi they both grow in the gallery
what's the point it's a great question i
don't have the answer
so let me go back again to this variety
because i'm not going to cover every one
and just
appreciate how many different kinds of
mechanisms there are
and it's because every ambrosia beetle
plate i told you
earlier that there's 12 different
inventions of
fungus farming in in bark beetles that's
each of these blue plates
each of them represents this amazing
discovery that hey
i can keep a really good fungus with me
go into the bark
but blow the bark into the wood and farm
it for food and each of those
seems to have required my kanji because
not a single one doesn't have some
kind of mycanjun or spore pocket
the hypothetical evolution here is that
superficial passengers that get really
good at being transferred on beetles
like dutch elm disease for example
eventually make their way into some kind
of internal structure that lets them be
carried even better
and maybe they start to be even better
food so the beetles aren't just
passively grazing on them anymore
and then the fungus loses the ability to
ever disperse itself
that's what i think of as ambrosia
butyls and
the my can jump is the lightning bolt
that lets that
happen what's also important here is
that there's a domino effect once
there's a symbiont ready for other
beetles to farm it is available
for free um so um my canjo appear to be
prerequisites for every shift
from bark beautifuls to fungus farming
although again
some park beetles have my kanji and do
rely on
fungi now ambrosia beetles aren't the
only animals that farm
we're one of them too and just like the
other animals
domestication requires genetic
bottlenecks
mycanja probably allow that at least i
think so every generation only a few
propagules into the organ
propagating selectively to make the next
inoculum perfect recipe
for domestication and co-evolution and i
talked about that domino effect
platypodine that other family that's all
in frozen beetles probably domesticated
with alfiela more than 100 million years
ago
and then there were trades that allowed
multiple groups to start farming and the
scalidinate this
passing the torch so to speak and then
some of those groups for whatever reason
got rid of this and picked up the sarah
cysteia state today
stratus at aca ambrosia fungi wow this
first one i've never been able to
pronounce that word it's an important
family
um we don't know why but for whatever
reason they seem to need bigger
mechanism for it
and gosh i could go on and on about all
the different abortion plans that have
been discovered recently
but that is for another time in the
future because today is about
pockets and those pockets do seem to
pre-date in evolutionary time
the fungi that they carry proving you
need a good solid pocket before you get
a stable
crop lineage so i'm going to
move towards closing up here because i
believe i've got about six minutes left
i want to encourage questions but if
each beetle my candy and fungus trio is
a unique symbiosis then i can just
define that symbiosis
and they're super important it's not
just butyl and fungus it's fetal fungus
mycanjun um they've evolved a bunch of
times that makes them a beautiful model
for studying the evolution of symbiosis
these should be a wonderful lab system
where else do you have 12 converged
evolutions to the same
organ doing the same thing but in
different ways imagine the different
kinds of tests that can be done on that
and i but do pockets matter are they def
of course i've just spent almost 15 very
dangerously close to 15 minutes
talking about that and and this beetle's
got a backpack on its
back it obviously thinks that they
matter but i can i can justify
them a little bit um for a few different
reasons this is why i think it's
important
to learn about and appreciate my kanji i
do appreciate
the little cartoon beetles keeping me on
track otherwise i'll tangent forever
future proofing understanding what fungi
can actually be vectored by
the next laurel wilt what's the next
disease to come here well we don't know
that unless we know
mycanja connecting potential invasives
to
native susceptible plants i can't kind
of feel like the missing puzzle piece
there
there's no such thing as overusing uh an
analogy right or a metaphor
okay so um
ecological context oh my gosh the amount
of fungi so
associated with the rosy goods is so
complex some are pathogens some are
nutritional mutualists
some are carried in my kanji some are
carried elsewhere
most of the fungi are poorly mapped into
this system and exists on a gradient
and it's really only the ones up here
that are the true co-evolved
nutritional symbionts but how do we know
ecological context how do we connect an
evolving lineage of insects
to an evolving wage a fungi oh i think
my kanji might be the missing piece
there
it leads to precision and management how
do we know how to manage
problems uh whether it's in the orchard
or the nursery or elsewhere
targeting them i can't was a pretty good
place if not targeting the fungus but
how do we know where the beetle
microbiome connects to the fungi that
might cause disease
i think it's my cancer what is in the
mic engine what's being transmitted by
the beatle
symbiotic theory how do ancestral
relationships how did they evolve to
become modern
mutualisms this is the study of how all
symbiosis evolved which can extend to
parasitisms and mutualism mycanja are
critical to ever figuring this out in
ambrosia beetles and it is not figured
out
because what we still don't know there
are so many mycanja that we don't even
know the fungi in them
we don't know what the gland cells are
actually secreting we don't know how
i can't recognize fungi and vice versa
we don't know the triggers
for fungi or beetle uh and there's a
working group called the bark beetle
microbiome that i'm a part of and i've
been happy to be a part of
which is working on starting to answer
many of those problems and putting out
resources to help others do it so in
conclusion
oh gosh i'm not going to read all that
my kanji are very important
and uh if you agree look out for this
book chapter
that's coming out soon uh that goes over
all of this in detail and
argues the point that my canja are
essential so with that
i want to thank all my collaborators i'm
sure i'm forgetting somebody here
uh that without them i couldn't have
made the few studies i mentioned
possible connecting my kanji to fungi
of course my pi from gosh feels like two
lives ago
back in the phd who was wonderful and
helped all this work
um i also want to thank uh teresa vlaska
and the whole pulaski lab here for
everything more about that
next time you see me but thank you so
much for listening to me talk about
pockets i will welcome any questions
thank you so much
thank you chase this was beautiful thank
you
um are there any questions for chase
might not be time no no no no we'll
we'll take all questions
questions questions
i have too many questions
great topic
[Music]
is there a way of studying
the yeast to filamentous
fungal uh transition
would that be a clue yes there is
uh in fact uh like most things in
ambrosia beetles and i didn't get to
pontificate about how important it is
that each of these is a separate evolved
group and way too often people make
assumptions across them
on beetle and fungus we have a pretty
good clue about how this happens in the
ophius so materials because ophiostoma
novo omai
and sporothrix and other ophiosomatilis
have density depending
dependent quorum like uh mechanisms to
go from
between states and we've got we've
gotten i said to say
we should say uh tom tom harrington had
preliminary data showing the same in
raphaelia
not enough to to to prove but it seems
like a good hunch
in this red assisted eca we have no idea
i can say
it didn't seem to me like density
dependent stuff worked yes it is a way
to do it
i have a follow-up question uh on um
related to gilian's question can you
actually obtain
um yeast um that you find in
in the pockets um in vitro
yeah can you can you explain what you
mean by yeast do you mean the yeast
so you mentioned that some of the
pockets are populated by
yeast um and others by spores that are
kind of arthrosports
just but no hyphy yes uh yes yeah
you you can uh in vitro
so can you make basically a test tube my
kanji is that what you're asking
it hasn't been tried to my knowledge
but it would be cool to do and i think
it's one of the obvious steps in
figuring out
how the micangel works would be to try
to replicate the compounds
we know from the 60s the compounds are
oily greasy
very lipidacious but also very full of
amino
acids but it's not clear what exactly
they do
it's not clear if they actually feed the
fungi through selective food
or if they just make a conducive
environment that the fungus
can handle better for example maybe they
handle lipids better
because okay i'm going out there but
maybe because they evolved from fungi
good to sticking to lipidacious fetal
surfaces
it's a logical ancestral history to me
but yes my cancer in a test tube would
be wonderful
thank you there is a question from chris
in chart
yeah is it known how the primary fungus
at the beetle farms removes
spores from other fungi or bacteria and
so i'm not exactly sure what you mean by
removes
spores but i think you mean in the
micandrum cycle
when other spores are excluded from the
micro exactly
how is that how does that exclusion
happen uh just through competitive
exclusion
and again this is never this has not
been demonstrated
this has not been demonstrated in action
in the laboratory
which i should give as a caveat but we
know that before the glands activate the
mechanic can be really dirty
it can have other molds they can have
dirt they can have
frass wood and the couple of ambrosia
spores and after the mycanjum
glands activate they fill with almost
entirely just
the mutualist and we know that when
they're in flight by that time
it is like 99.99 pure
mutualist and the mechanism that makes
sense
is that the other trash and gunk in
there was pushed out and there's
actually been beautifully
illustrated cross sections of icandja
over the year
showing and it's a lot of junk going to
pure
like beautiful mutualist sports wow
um you mentioned um defenses
three defenses and i did i kind of
missed this bit
so beatles obviously would um
induce defenses but they are different
defenses that
fungi would induce because beetle
defenses are
the fundraiser uh defenses three
defenses
against insects are just morning acid um
based and uh against fungi are salicylic
acid
based in kind of generalizing can you
talk about this a little bit or or
elaborate elucidate i can and those
defenses vary a lot i'm not an expert in
them but they vary from really heavy
resident production
to other active defenses in the tree
that make things bad for the beetles
but because the beetle is the vector for
the fungus and the fungus cannot get in
without the beetle successfully digging
in most ambrosia beetles don't have the
behavior in the first place to attack
living trees
they actually look for ethanol that's
given off by the process of
decomposition that is their major
attractant
so behavior is the biggest barrier to
ambrosia beetles going into living wood
in the first place
meaning the fungus can never go there to
meet these defenses
um but second an ambrosia beetle that
digs in and realizes it's made a mistake
will usually leave and it will do this
before it's in the sapwood or before
it's had a chance to establish the
fungus well there's more competitive
fungi in the phloem
or maybe they just don't get in deep
enough but
when this breaks down is when disaster
happens because
the red bay ambrosia beetle the one that
causes laurel wilt in the u.s
has an unusual biology one that it also
does in its native range in china
of having the behavior to attack living
trees
and to dig in a good bit now it backs
out again afterwards
and tries again but it digs in enough to
inoculate the fungus
and once the fungus is there it does
indeed overcome the tree defenses
and cause disease and so this is kind of
how laurelwood is first
introduced it's once the tree declines
more that the beetles can come back and
really colonize so yeah
i would say absolutely the defenses are
different it's the beetle behavior
that makes the difference and they are
very particular
thank you any other questions
i'll venture a question yeah please yeah
so
i was just curious um if there's any
um entomopathogenic fungi
that um prey on these beetles or if any
generalist insect pathogens can infect
these beetles
um and whether there's there's some
degree of
recognition of their fungal partner that
distinguishes between
uh mounting and immune defense perhaps
um
i don't know much about insect
immunology
though if i imagine that is an excellent
yeah yeah yeah
that is an excellent question um because
internal pathogens
and fungus pathogens have been a really
big deal in other fungus forming
systems now i can answer
with the very general yes there are
intimate pathogens
that kill ambrosia beetles and they have
indeed been introduced
uh as control mechanisms for ambrosia
beetles now i'm gonna put my
foot in my mouth here but i think it was
bavaria basiana
and one more i could do a download
google search but there's no honor in
that so there there have been two
at least two intimate pathogens that
have been used for insect control
i'm not the one to answer that the one
who is is louella castrillo at
usda ars here in ithaca as well as uh
john vandenberg who is there who have
both
done work on exactly this in the field
and i'm sure many others
um so i am not the i'm not the expert to
answer that but
yes okay cool yeah i've worked a little
bit on bavaria i know it's a
super generalist so that would make
sense yeah yeah and
it turns in pink terms yeah it does
is fun you know you get a little fun
with your control yeah
thank you good question hi cherry i do
have a question
i tried it really stunning that ambrosia
fungi can
survive in really oily environments of
the
of the nitrogen and also these really
cellulose and ziggy rich environments
of the tree do you think that has any
connection to the
biomorphic lifestyle of these fungi has
anyone ever tried growing the hypo stage
in like these oily rich environments or
vice versa
sorry i didn't quite catch the end
growing in a what rich environment
all right uh have you uh has anyone ever
tried growing the
like hypo stage of these ambrosia fungi
in these oily rich environments
and we sort of lease like sages in the
cellulose rich environment was it
protein-rich environment
is that did you say protein rich oh it
goes protein rich
yes sorry i think i must have missed our
admitted rich
oh no look rich little rich environment
yes yes um
yes gosh it's been a little bit but
following the advice of the uh
expert helen frankie grossman the most
important impression fungus researcher
uh who said you could pour olive oil on
the cultures and get them to
change i tried it i didn't get it to
work you know how that works sometimes
it takes a magic
touch um i did try growing them on wood
sterilized wood chips i've tried uh
proline
additions which was supposed to be amino
acid that will help trigger
my candle growth others you know folks
decades ago said they got it to work
it was one of those little side projects
that never yielded but certainly it has
to be possible
they also respond to beetle grazing so
just the act of the beetle eating the
fungus
can be what it requires to start making
food to actually fruit otherwise they'll
be sterile
and so some authors decades ago would
let little beetles walk around their
cultures
and eat and it would cause sporulation
because there's really
three forms of fungus something i didn't
get into
the mechanical form where it can divide
and grow and
you know proliferate the filamentous
form where it grows into the wood
and extends it doesn't do any wood decay
these are not wood decay fungus
fungi but extended extract nutrients and
there is the ambrosial form
where it commits all of this energy to
like completely ridiculous spores that
are really tasty
all three of those um it switches
between under different
triggers but uh yeah i have tried
similar
culture manipulations just no no luck
a really fascinating system absolutely
yeah there's there's just so many
avenues just
begging to be explored uh under this
symbiosis and then you can do it 12
times because once you do it for one
group
you don't know it evolved the same way
so yeah thanks for that question
excellent other questions
hey chase um great talk again uh
uh one question just follow up to
returns point
um or just follow up to your answer you
said they will change
uh the basically they're sort of like
life stage whether they proliferate or
not
uh when they switch this environment
have anyone
tried to sort of like trigger that in
laboratory
conditions
the closest to that well
sorry triggering what part the fungus
responding or the mechanism responding
uh the the fungus or the ambrosia fungal
want to trigger that into spiralization
like sort of imitating when it's
changing from
potential to for example the the wood
yeah
uh yes it has been tried
um a couple caveats so one the reverse
was tried
back in the 70s by izol schneider who
was a legend of
um metabolism and glands and was the
single most important study
in my my tangent cycle theory because
she actually
looked at the mycanja and washed the
glands activate when they when the
fungus
touched them and then grow only
instead of the other fungi in the
secretions and so did observe
that direction the filamentous to my
tangent form
you don't have to work hard for the
other direction because plating the
micangile form on media
it just goes to filamentous it's not
that it needs a trigger to go
filamentous it seems to be that it loses
the
the context the micro environment of the
mechanism and then goes to filamentous
as its default
state so it's really just a binary
is it in the michaelangelo environment
or not if it is turn into a
michaelangelo's state
that could be enough for the advantage
they have
in the micanja is recognizing that
they're in one and
starting to grow and proliferate as a
single cell when the other
interlopers and i don't like to use that
term because it's loaded they the other
fungi might have rolls in the mechanism
but maybe the other interlopers don't
know that they're wasting time is
hyphy and they get pushed up just a
theory
but yeah it's observed all the time it's
the best way to isolate them
the fungi from the beetles
any other questions
i don't hear any
chase thank you very much this was
wonderful thank you and and good luck
with your uh
ambrosia fungal pursuits and uh thank
you very much
guys
we'll see you next week i guess thanks
chase
thank you thank you
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu